Ngài Hôm Hà Thánh Chính, tại hôm Gỹ Thường Nguyen Gầu Keepers ở New York Mỹ, Tỳ Phú Vinh Gết từng bố sẽ gió chính
trong 12 triệu đồ là Mỹ, thông qua quy bíu em Melinda Gates để hỗ trợ quyết toàn cầu phòng trong biểu thát EVA,
cũng như bạch lào và số zet. Quảng tiền này bằng mức đồng góc của Vị Tỳ Phú và năm 2020,
nhưng năm nay, số tiền của ý nghĩa hơn khi dễn ra trong bối cảnh nhiều chuyện phủ,
đặc biệt là Mỹ đang cách giả mạnh biệt sợ ý tế, tại sự kiện Tỳ Phú Vinh Gết Cảnh Báo,
nếu sự thật ở này tiếp diễn, hàng chiều trẻ em có thể từ vong,
vuy những kân bệnh lệ ra có thích ngàn trạm được.
Ông cục đưa ra giận trường rằng, ở miếng bắt như zet vẻ,
cứ bây chẻ thì có một em không qua được tuổi thứ năm.
Nó về sự đồng góc của bản thân, nhà sáng lát mai của sốt,
nhưng mạnh, một việc trở của ý Viu em Melinda Gates không thể thấy thế trên nhận của chính phủ.
Nhưng có thể giuy chỉ khi bỏng về múng điều suốt phỏe toàn cầu,
nhưng năm hàng hi bấm rơi,
ông cũng tại thằng định kế hoạt trò đi và nếu toàn bộ tại sản hai chăm tỷ đối la,
trước năm, hàng hiệp bộ lắm để kiểu thêm hàng triệu sinh mạo.
Tại sự kiện thủ tưởng tới bàn nhà Pedro Sanchez,
cũng được chào dạy, lâu bầu của Kipper,
nhờ tăng mạnh năng vóc, cho khủy toàn cầu và Linh Meng Bắc Xin gà vi.